[Musique]
au Moyen-Orient le golf arabo-persique
s'étire dans une position centrale sur
la rive sud l'État du Qatar occupe une
péninsule de moins de 11500 km car près
de 200 fois plus petite que l'Arabie
Saoudite jusqu'au 20e siècle la
presquille a tiré ses principales
ressources de la mer toujours proche
dans sa plus grande largeur en effet le
pays mesure à peine 80
km une multitude gravite autour d'un
territoire qui est pour l'essentiel une
vaste plain
désertique le climat et l'aridité du sol
laissent peu de chance à la végétation
sauvage en hiver les averses ne sont pas
rares alors le désert reprend des
couleurs la gestion rigoureuse de l'eau
et sa distribution méthodique permettent
au désert de fleurir au plus fort de
l'été
pour sortir de sa coquille le Qatar a
longtemps misé sur l'huîre
perlière la perle a lancé l'économie
d'un pays auquel la famille altani a
donné sa constitution et sa
notoriété sur la côte est la capitale
s'est métamorphosé depuis un
demi-siècle do abrite 80% de la
population
nationaleroiss rapide respecte les
traditions dans un émirat dont
l'indépendance a été proclamée en
1971 l'État du Qatar a élevé la santé le
bien-être et l'éducation au rang des
priorités nationales il en va de même
pour l'éducation physique et la pratique
du sport le pays affiche d'ailleurs ses
ambitions à travers l'organisation
d'événements sportifs d'envergure
internationale l'enseignement est une
autre prior
laéatar doit en tirer
profit la femme y trouve les moyens de
son émancipation en accédant au savoir
et en maîtrisant les techniques modernes
la qualité de l'éducation et les
contacts permanents avec l'extérieur
Assur au pays la diffusion de ses
valeurs dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui mais la révolution
numérique associe les coutumes
ancestrales
le tiers seulement de la population est
originaire du
pays le reste est composé de
travailleurs expatriés qui constitue un
apport en savoir-faire et en main
d'œuvre indispensable à l'économie
nationale les coutumes sont celles d'un
État où la religion musulmane est
pratiquée par la quasittalité de la
population le Qatar est un pays où
l'islam est
modéré les convictions religieuses sont
bien intégré au monde
contemporain l'intégration de l'habitat
dans l'environnement révèle le même sens
de
l'adaptation depuis des siècles les
tribus nomades ont appris à vivre dans
un milieu hostile
sédentarisé les nomades s'inspirent
parfois de leurs tentes pour construire
leurs
habitation pour s'abriter du vent du
sable et du soleil on n'a pas trouvé
meilleure protection légèreté et lign
fluide contrastent avec les formes d'une
architecture importée par les
occidentaux au début du 16e
[Musique]
siècle le pays alluma beaucoup de
convoitises dès le milieu du 20e
siècle la richesse perlière n'explique
pas à elle seule l'intérêt que le Qatar
suscite
une nouvelle perle sortie du sol un vrai
pactol la troisième réserve de gaz
naturel au
monde le gaz et le pétrole fournissent
85 % des recettes à l'exportation ils
alimentent aussi la production
énergétique le transport de l'énergie
électrique est nécessaire au
développement d'un coup de baguette
magique le désert a changé il est
parfois difficile de faire la différence
entre Mirage et réalité
le dromadaire le vaisseau du désert
s'est acclimaté à la ville alors que les
voitures désormais traversent le
désert de nombreuses implantations
industrielles apparaissent qui récl
toujours plus
d'infrastructure les engins du génie
civil accélèrent la
[Musique]
cadence
le Qatar traverse le temps à grandes
enjambé il relie son histoire millénaire
au futur en
marche la croissance économique est
soutenue dans un pays qui approche le
million d'habitants mais la perle du
passé n'est pas oubliée la coquille et
son profil harmonieux influen les
urbanistes et les architectes pour
dessiner les ensembles immobiliers de
[Musique]
demain tr
d'arraied
qui s'impose à
l'horizon le Qatar a bien préparé le
terrain de son envol et l'objectif est
ambitieux au marge du désert un pays
crée des formes nouvelles les formes de
son
avenir
[Musique]
sortie du désert DOA a été fondé au
milieu du 19e siècle à l'époque du
protectorat
britannique sur le front de mer la
corniche déroule 7 km dans la
perspective futuriste du quartier de
West
Bay DOA était à l'origine qu'un petit
village de pêcheurs mais le temps s'est
enfui la Corniche est un lieu de
rendez-vous pour les
flanneurs le vendredi les do les bateaux
traditionnel il débarque des familles
entières on y vient piqueniquer sur
l'herbe au pied des immeubles
modernes bien qu'aucune restriction
vestimentaire ne soit imposée aux femmes
la plupart d'entre elles pent la longue
ABAA
noire
à l'extrémité de West Bay les premiers
architectes déjà avait fait preuve
d'originalité aujourd'hui une véritable
forêt de grciel a vu le
jour pourtant il n'était pas nécessaire
de construire en hauteur car l'espace
ici n'a jamais
manqué les buildings sont les signes
extérieurs de la réussite et DOA voit
l'avenir en
grand
[Musique]
une architecture sans contrainte a
permis de fusionner tradition et
modernisme Ibrahim jaida
architecte le ciel est la seule limite
ici au Qatar pour un architecte dans
beaucoup d'endroits en Europe et en
Occident on est très limité par les
constructions
avoisinantes ici la seule limite c'est
le ciel en terme de style de hauteur de
fonctionnalité il y a beaucoup d'idées
osées ici au Qatar
et pourquoi pas des gondoliers vénitiens
godillant au pied des immeubles
oui souvent il suffit
d'oser car les moyens sont à la hauteur
des
ambitions mais ce n'est sûrement pas si
[Musique]
simple le problème le plus important
c'est l'échelle car ici on n pas
l'habitude de construire en hauteur
traditionnellement on construit de
manière horizontale donc le dé de
construire très haut tout en conservant
notre identité plus on construit haut
plus on risque d'oublier notre
identité partout les lignes orientales
rivalisent en élégance avec les courbes
occidentales l'économie florissante de
l'État du Qatar repose sur des assis
solid le gouvernement a choisi de
diversifier ses ressources en faisant de
la capitale
importante place
financière ainsi la rue Hamad alkabir
est-elle devenue la rue des banques la
rue où tout a tendance à prendre la
couleur de l'or même les
perles mais ici personne n'oublie que
tout a commencé avec des perles pêchées
au fond de l'eau au prix d'efforts
considérabl
impossible également d'ignorer
l'empreinte musulmane elle forme un axe
autour duquel le catar
s'enroule la spirale du minaré suit la
trajectoire d'un monde en
mouvement toutes les composantes de la
société traditionnelle restent bien
présentes mais elles sont
actualisé l'architecture en est un bel
exemple à travers le musée des arts
islamiques
son jeu de cube subtile a été conçu par
l'auteur de la pyramide du Louvre
l'architecte américain
pay madame sabia ALIR dirige le
musée quand on lui a demandé de dessiner
le musée des islamique à
doaing s'est engagé dans un long voyage
à travers le monde islamique il s'est
mis à la recherche de l'essence même de
l'architecture islamique et ce voyage
l'a conduit d'Afrique du Nord en IR en
Égypte partout au Moyen-Orient et ce
qu'il a fait c'est tracer pour
l'architecture islamique traditionnelle
la voie vers la
modernité les objets présentés viennent
de trois continents ils couvrent 13
siècles d'une civilisation
brillante cela va de la poterie des
objets en vert ou en métal au tapis en
fait des objets anglais jusqu'à la soie
et de Cordoba en Espagne jusqu'à
samarcand en Asie centrale un vaste
périère géographique et du 7e siècle des
origines de l'islam jusqu'à nos
jours à proximité du musée et à l'ombre
rectiligne des grat ciel un chantier
naval hors du temps construit encore les
dos selon les techniques anciennes le
dos est une embarcation très répandue
dans l'océan Indien et notamment le long
des côtes du golf il est en principe
fabriqué en te un bois
imputble
[Musique]
on assemble la coque avec des chevilles
de bois en donnant une forme carrée à la
poupe le bois de te a la propriété de
durcir lorsqu'il est mouillé l'étv du
dos a imprimé sa forme dans le
ciel
[Musique]
autre tradition le souc un mot qui en
arabe désigne le marché installé dans la
vieille
ville le vieux sou de DOA a été restauré
mais il a conservé ses activités réparti
en différents
secteurs instrument de musique
traditionnel confection du pain
traditionnel tout ici fait référence au
passé
local au sou au bijou les pierres et les
métaux précieux sont par les joaliers
cataris depuis des
générations les artisans ici ont trèsôt
disposer d'un matériau apprécié dans le
monde entier les perles
naturelles aujourd'hui les perles sont
importées descendant d'un pêcheur de
perles vendeur de perles un artiste
réalise d'étonnants tableaux en bois en
exploitant les nuances de différentes
ces uvres rappellent parfois le dur
métier de ses
ancêtres il rehaus ses compositions de
perles véritable avec un sens inoui du
détail un travail d'une grande
finesse dans cet art du bois il y a deux
choses l'art de sculpter par exemple
pour faire l'image de
l'émire et l'autre c'est assembler les
pièces de bois de différentes couleurs
il y a un très grand nombre de pièces de
bois dans ces
portraits une représentation en trois
dimensions plus expressive qu'une
photo dans le souc aux fruits et légumes
on est surpris par la variété des
espèces et des couleurs quand on connaî
les limites de l'agriculture au Qatar la
plupart des produits arrivent sur les
étales en provenance du monde entier une
infime minorité de la population dans le
secteur
[Musique]
agricole les marchandises encombrantes
ou remuant sont proposé à la vente dans
un autre souc l'éprouvant climat
désertique et l'absence d'herbage
entrave le développement de
l'élevage les Soues traditionnelles
cohabitent désormais avec les Soues
contemporain fores modne formes
exotiques
à l'intérieur l'air est toujours frais
et aucune brise ne viendra chasser les
nuages de la voûte
[Musique]
céleste les centres commerciaux sont de
gigantesqu bulles d'air conditionné des
bulles affranch des contraintes de la
géographie pe impor te la température
extérieure le patin à glace fait tourner
les
têtes mais rien ne peut refroidir
l'attrait des cataris pour les produits
de
[Musique]
consommation
autre plaisir des cataris le parfum le
mot parfum désignait à l'origine des
substances aromatiques que l'on
brûlait le parfum est connu au
Moyen-Orient depuis
l'Antiquité les traditions
s'entretiennent avec soin au Qatar le
pays n'est pas replié sur lui-même pour
autant il est résolument tourné vers
l'avenir et vers
l'extérieur c'est précisément le but de
la chaîne de télévision aljazera créée
en 1996 par la volonté de l'émire la
chaîne d'information est devenue l'une
des plus diffusés au monde tout en
éclairant l'actualité du point de vue
arabe la chaîne a élevé un monument à la
mémoire des journalistes tués en
mission le mur de la liberté rappelle
l'engagement des jist et les risques de
leur
métier un musée a été aménagé
rassemblant les souvenirs des
journalistes de la chaîne mort au
service de
[Musique]
l'information pour préparer l'avenir le
Qatar a créé la fondation du Qatar
dirigé par Son Altesse Royale l'épouse
de l'mire en
[Musique]
personne en reprenant les lignes de
l'architecture traditionnelle mais aussi
en sollicitant les maîtres de
l'architecture contemporaine un immense
complexe a été érigé education
City l'idée était simple mais
audacieuse fonder un campus non pas en
faisant à une seule université mais en
regroupant sur le même site quelquesunes
des meilleures universités du monde les
moyens investis les techniques de pointe
et les professeurs recrutés à travers le
monde ont rapidement donné à l'ensemble
une réputation
internationale pour s'ouvrir sur le
monde et mieux le comprendre les
couleurs vives sont tout indiqué
lorsqu'on cherche à intéresser les
enfants l'ouverture d'esprit et la
objectifs qui ont motivé la création
d'aljira channel la chaîne vise
l'éducation et le divertissement des
enfants arabes elle est doté de moyens
qui lui permettent de produire de
nombreux programmes Ludo
éducatif l'ampleur des réalisations de
la fondation du Qatar donne la mesure de
ses ambitions
le nouveau centre de congrès sera le
plus vaste du
Moyen-Orient les palmiers ne
reconnaissent plus leur
désert le Qatar a vu les choses en grand
autour du stade Khalifa à la pointe de
l'architecture sportive la cité des
Sports est dominée par une tour de 320 m
en forme de
flamme
la qualité des installations sportives
est un atout pour le pays qui a organisé
les Jeux asiatiques en 2006 le Qatar
rêve déjà aux Jeux
Olympiques pour déclarer sa flamme
olympique les infrastructures sont
évidemment un atout
[Musique]
majeur le Qatar dispose également d'un
outil pédagogique unique appelé aspire
l'encadrement des champions en herbe est
la vocation de l'institution le Qatar
veut favoriser la réussite sportive il
nourrit par là l'ambition d'imposer son
nom à l'échelle
mondiale haft est un dirigeant
d'aspirepire l'Académie pour
l'excellence dans le sport est unique
non seulement elle est dotée des STR les
plus performantes mais ell possède les
meilleurs programmes pour l'éducation
des jeunes
athlètes le but est d'en faire des
sportif de haut
niveau l'idée de base est de créer ici
des Champions et aussi de développer la
culture du sport au
catar l'ascension des sportifs Qataris
sur la scène internationale est à ce
prix les jeunes sélectionnés sont
entirement pris en charge il part une
vie communautaire o les cours généraux
font partie d'un emploi du temps
[Musique]
chargé le sport ici contribue à créer
des formes nouvelles les formes de
[Musique]
l'avenir
l'organisation de grandes rencontres
sportives donne au Qatar une notoriété
mondiale mais il a fallu d'abord vaincre
le
[Musique]
désert le Golf Club de DOA organise les
Masters du Qatar une compétition
internationale de
renaom la performance est remarquable
car le parcours de 18 trous a prévu les
canards en plein désert tout en
intégrant les
cactus sur le luxueux gazon on pourrait
confondre balle et
perles
[Musique]
le cheval a toujours accompagné les
populations N de Moyen-Orient il
appartient à la culture arabe depuis des
siècles l'élevage et le dressage ont
trouvé au Qatar une terre de
prédilection le cheval est une des
grandes passions de l'émire ses aras
sont réputés dans le monde entier et ses
chevaux accumulent les
[Musique]
récompenses
le goût de la compétition commence à
mobiliser les
Qataris la présence prolongée des
Anglais dans le pays explique pour une
large part l'attrait pour les courses
ipiques le faucon est un autre animal
fétiche au
Qatar il est uné à son maître par une
sorte de
complicité les Faucons ont leurs
hôpitaux avec salle d'attente
l'oiseau se blesse souvent car il chasse
en percutant ses proies à grande vitesse
les fractures sont
fréquentes les interventions
chirurgicales sont réalisé sous
anesthésie ces petites blessures ici ont
été causé au cours de
l'entraînement au moment où il s'est
posé au sol ou lorsqu'ilrapé un oiseau
dans le
désert il a dû toucher une
[Musique]
pierre l'opération se déroule sous le
regard inquiet du
propriétaire le faucon dressé a une
grande valeur affective et
pécunière autre type d'intervention le
remplacement d'une
plume on sectionne la plume
abîmée chaque plume estéférc selon sa
taille et son
emplacement la tige se glisse tout
simplement dans
l'aile pas besoin de fixation le faucon
se réveille prêt à reprendre du
service rendez-vous dans le désert pour
une partie de
chasse la proie va être lâchée
[Musique]
le faucon
s'élance le fauconnier garde le contact
visuel le rapace fond sur sa proie qui
n'a aucune chance le faucon est l'animal
le plus rapide de la
création un autre faucon prend son
envol
mais bientôt le rapace
disparaît heureusement le fauconier a
plus d'un gadget dans son
4 on a retrouvé le faucon la proie
s'était réfugié dans un buisson une fois
débusqu elle est aussitô attrapé par le
rapace récp cheur peut dévorer sa
[Musique]
victime mais pourquoi ne l'a-t-il pas
attrapé
plusutôt c'est à cause du vent qu'il a
mis longtemps à
l'attraper autrement il l'aurait attrapé
facilement une antenne et un émetteur
ont permis de localiser le
[Musique]
faucon
cap vers l'ouest à travers le
[Musique]
désert des silhouettes familièr
apparaissent un autre animal
[Musique]
traditionnel à l'horizon un camp de
tente a été dressé à la manière des
Bédouins
les cataris restent très attachés au
mode de vie et au coutumes
ancestrales sans qu'il renie pour autant
les avantages du monde
moderne dans le camp l'habituelle
répartition des tâches est respecté ce
sont les femmes qui confectionnent les
ornements portés par les dromadaires
[Musique]
prépare aussi lesam les
beign
tout le monde est là en l'honneur de
l'animal qui a permis l'existence dans
le désert le
[Musique]
dromadaire pour le dromadaire un grand
jour commence par une bonne
[Musique]
douche
il y a beaucoup de gens qui aiment les
dromadair pour moi c'est
un ici on aime les courses de
dromire vous savez j'ai gardé mon de
B les cours de dromada l'événement
sucite l'engou des
catar on commence par un petit
échauffement une silhouette étrange est
apparu sur les champs de cour un robot
que l'on habille d'une casque de
jocket la cravache est commandée à
distance par la voie
ou par pression sur un
porte-clé à l'origine les dromadaires
étaient montés par des enfants les
cataris ont été les premiers à adopter
les jockets robots désormais tous les
jockets ont le même poids
quand vient le moment du départ les
dromadaires doivent s'aligner dans le
sens de la
course le règlement ne prévoit pas
d'exception tout rentre vite dans
l'ordre
prêt par les DROM s accompagné par le
peloton des
voitures
la piste est bordée de deux voies où les
propriétaires pilotent à la fois leur
véhicule et leur
[Musique]
champions
dans leur enclos les femelles semblent
bien agitées
elles n'ont pas oublié la mise en pli
elles ont sorti leurs plus beaux
atours que se
passe-t-il un jury de connaisseur va
désigner la plus jolie d'entre
elles l'allure générale et de nombreux
détails font l'objet d'une notation
rigoureuse un concours de beuté ne peut
souffrir aucune
contestation
et la gagnante
est une nouvelle star est née et le
concours se termine en danse et en
chansonق
الاق
الاول
[Musique]
plus à l'ouest sur le site de zicrit le
vent chargé de sable sculpte la roche
calcaire selon sa
fantaisie dans les jeux d'ombre les
formes se renouvellent sans
cesse ici aussi la créativité a le ciel
comme seule
limite
[Musique]
la côte ouest est baignée par le golfe
de
bar les larges plages pourraient
accueillir les baigneurs en grand nombre
mais l'activité ici est entièrement
dédié à l'exploitation du pétrole la
côte occidentale concentre en effet les
principaux puits de Péro pays les
oléoducs serpentent à travers toute la
région le pétrole a été découvert ici
par les Anglais à la fin des années
1930 le Qatar entrait dans une are
[Musique]
nouvelle au départ de la capitale et en
prenant la direction du nord le désert
retrouve vite ses droits plus on avance
et plus on s'enfonce dans un paysage
hospitalier le désert néanmoins n'est
pas qu'une vaste étendue sans
vie surprise on y rencontre des cultures
sur des parcelles soigneusement
délimitées autre surprise les cultures y
sont d'une grande
variété mais la végétation ne peut
survivre sans l'appui d'une irrigation
systématique on réussit même à cultiver
des tomates grâce à une gestion
rigoureuse de l'eau pour certains
légumes le Qatar fournit 70 % de sa
consommation étonnant on élève dans le
désert des vaches laitières un animal
dont la résistance à la chaleur n'est
pas le point fort et pourtant ça marche
surtout lorsqu'on décide de faire appel
à la
technologie lorsque la Chaleur risque
d'indisposer les vaches des
humidificateurs entrent en action et les
stor sont
[Musique]
baissés la traite des vaches se déroule
dans un environnement quasi
asceptisé et l'informatique intervient à
tous les stades de la
production la traite des vaches est
organisée par ordinateur ce qui permet
d'optimiser la quantité et la qualité du
lait la technologie aide aussi à
rationaliserensem
[Musique]
certaines opérations restent manuelles
mais c'est l'ordinateur qui détermine la
quantité de lait à
prélever on TR les vach de ou TR fois
par
jour chaque vache un numéro et ellete un
transpondur en liaison avec un
ordinateur qui traite toutes les données
sur
l'animal
autre type d'élevage
l'orix l'animal emblématique du Qatar
vivait à l'état sauvage dans la région
mais il a bien failli
disparaître les gazelles font également
partie de la faune
locale elles ont été décimées par les
chasseurs mais prospè aujourd'hui dans
ferme d'élevage on les apprécie pour
leur viande et leur
[Musique]
cuir
les îles qui bordent le littoral
accueillent les oiseaux de
passage une épaissement grve par endroit
fait obstacle au
[Musique]
désert plus au nord la route du désert
se rapproche de la mer les localités
sont tournées vers le Golfe et leurs
ressources en dépendent les dos ne
servent pas à la promenade mais à la
[Musique]
pêche le port d'Al r pointe à
l'extrémité nord de la
péninsule la pêche est une activité
traditionnelle au Qatar aujourd'hui ceux
qui en vivent sont des travaille
im défense contre les dangers venus de
la mer le fort de alzubara fut érigé en
1938 le Qatar répondait alors aux
fortification construit par le bah la
région se trouvait déjà au cœur d'un
trafic commercial très
dense mir est
archéologue au 18e et 19e siècle
zubara commcial pour l'ensemble de la
région du Golfe
Arabique zubara était en contact avec
Basora au nord Oman au sud et de là avec
l'Afrique de l'Ouest et vers l'Est avec
la vallée de l'Indus et même la
Chine à l'intérieur du fort sont exposés
les objets trouvés lors de fouilles
pratiqué dans les ruines de la
localité la ville a connu jadis une
activité
intense
il y avait un port important à zubara
mentionné dans les livres
d'histoire zubara était aussi connu pour
l'industrie
perlière les perles étai exporté vers de
nombreux pays zubara était un port
international où on pouvait utiliser
toutes sortes de
devises la cité de alzubara protégée par
des ramp dès le 18e siècle éta
idéalement
situé l'Ance du site prouve l'ouverture
du pays au monde extérieur n'est pas que
de l'histoire
récente en direction du sud il suffit de
parcourir 75 km à peine pour atteindre
l'Arabie Saoudite le sud est une région
où le désert impose sa loi dès que l'on
quitte la
[Musique]
capitale la route ne rencontrera plus
d'obstacles à part les immense d'une de
sable seul les lignes de la côte
arrêtent le désert
[Musique]
soudain derrière la montagne de sable
surgit un des fleurons de l'économie
Catarie l'énorme complexe industriel de
messayed on y traite notamment le gaz
naturel qui constitue la principale
richesse du
pays un fabuleux gisement un des plus
vastes du monde a été découvert au Qatar
au début des années
1970 les équipements en place àed à la
pointe de la technologie il s'agit de
refroidir le gaz naturel pour le
liqufier et permettre son transport sous
une forme stable et peu
volumineuse une véritable ville
industrielle a été créée de toutes
pièces et les installations de messayed
se développent sans
cesse si la consommation mondiale de gaz
naturel se maintenait à son niveau
actuel et si le Qatar maintenait le
rythme de ses exportations on estime
l'exploitation des réserves pourrait se
prolonger pendant plus de de
siècles l'avenir du pays commence
[Musique]
ici vers le sud le plus simple est de
garder la côte en ligne de
[Musique]
mireobable
se détache entre M et
désert une oasis de confort et de
tranquillité mais soudain des cavaliers
bédouins apparaissent en costume
d'apparat les couleurs nationales
flottent
fièrement
étonnant un déjeuner sur l'herbe et de
jeunes supporters qui annonce la couleur
explication le
vélo en janvier le Tour du Qatar prépare
la saison cycliste sous la direction de
l'ancien champion Eddie MERX je pense
que pour préparer une saison c'est c'est
l'idéal les étapes sont pas trop longues
que les coururs sont logé chaque jour
dans le même hôtel donc c'est l'idéal
pour préparer et pour améliorer sa
condition
[Musique]
c'est le seul endroit du pays où le
paysage ondule sous les barcanes c'est
d'une de sable en forme de
[Musique]
croissant
trace
silhouette
[Musique]
forme le 44 dans les dunes est devenu le
loisir favori des
cataris
le terrain de jeu est
infini ce qui est le plus intéressant
c'est de trouver des dunes où personne
n'a jamais
roulé trouver des terrains nouveaux
c'est un vrai hob vous
savez
[Musique]
le terrain de jeu se renouvelle car le
vent régulièrement efface les traces et
le désert se prête au véhicules de tout
genre c'est comme un safari on part d'un
endroit et on va à un
autre
[Musique]
la côte au sud mène à un détroit qui
donne accès à une petite mer
intérieure de l'autre côté c'est
l'Arabie
Saoudite des tentes ponctuent
l'immensité pour quelques heures ou
quelques jours certains cataris viennent
y communier avec le désert une manière
de retrouver les origines ce qui ne veut
pas dire renier le monde
[Musique]
moderne la chambre n'est pas en toile et
la climatisation fait vite oublier la
température extérieure
[Musique]
la nuit
tombe pour les aventuriers d'un jour il
est temps de regagner le monde
contemporain la réalité se fond alors
dans un mirage moderne un jimkanana
[Musique]
hallucinant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la lune allume sur doas des rangs de
perles le désert s'est retiré mais les
repères sont restés moderne ou
traditionnel la maison comme une tente
s'est illuminée pour la
fête au pied des gratciel subsistent les
coutumes ancestrales la mosquée aussi
est un repère on célèbre un mariage les
invités viennent présenter leurs
hommages les hommes se réunissent ici
les femmes sont ailleurs comme dans le
désert les cafetières
chauffent
l'ensang reste une marque de
bienvenue comme les dates au cœur de la
ville moderne la tradition et le
présent les perles de lumière amènent au
spectacle des danses
traditionnelles une danse bédouine
réservée aux grandes occasions la danse
du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sabre
après les danses le
repas de l'agneau et du riz c'est le
macbou le plat
traditionnel on mange avec la main
droite uniquement la main
[Musique]
droite
demain pour le marier commencera une vie
nouvelle dans l'ombre ou la lumière le
Qatar est en pass de réussir son Paris
concilier identité et
modernité comme un rêve éveillé le pays
émerge tout droit du
désert presque sans transition de la
tente au grat ciel il est entrer dans
une époque nouvelle il faut se frotter
les yeux aujourd'hui pour croire ce que
l'on voit
les poètes arabes voyaient jadis dans
les perles les larmes de la
lune les perles contemporaines ont
bouleversé la vie des cataris mais pas
les valeurs essentielles
elles sont devenues perles
[Musique]
d'avenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]